thanks to curiosity stream the home of
the best documentaries on the internet
and nebula for sponsoring this video
climate change meme review hey everyone
so i thought i'd try something a little
different today
i put a tweet out asking people to send
me their best their spiciest
climate change related memes and i
thought i would in this video go through
them
and uh it's like mean peer review we're
gonna have a look at perhaps how
accurate some of these memes are
and how much they actually reflect the
dark humor within me
okay let's get into it how to kiss
someone who doesn't support urgent
climate action
um oh do i want to advocate this
climb meme change we're gonna see a lot
of climb change
in this video if you haven't followed
them on instagram they're like the go-to
account
do we need urgent action on climate
change 100 we are in a situation where
we're a pivotal couple of decades and we
absolutely need to take action
do i think that people mid sex should
rip each other's heads off
if they don't advocate that action
i'm gonna cage my bets here and say no
that's how we're starting sure okay
[Laughter]
what this will affect the trout
population yeah i think a uh chick-fil-a
style impact probably would
this is kind of interesting though
because it's like representative of how
people
don't care about an abstract concept
like climate change but if you
really like trout then suddenly wait a
minute a change in the environmental
conditions means they're not going to
breed as effectively i don't get to fish
them
i want to do something about this it's
like nimbyism not in my backyard like
this kind of thing that like if it's a
general
principle it's not important or as if
it's specific to you something you care
about then it becomes important
[Laughter]
oh boy it's so true the amount of
progress we've made
has been uneven let's put it like that
in some parts of the world we've made
some fantastic progress like the eu
is really leading the charge in terms of
like actual meaningful stuff
and the energy transition is definitely
happening but this meme really does
convey just how
uh limited the accomplishments so far
that isn't to say that we
should give up the accomplishments so
far are significant because we've
taken the first steps but that's all
they are they're the first steps
oh i hate this i hate the plastic straw
debate
there's a great figure i have to find it
to put it in the video of
people's perception of like their um how
much
changing a certain behavior is going to
benefit the environment in terms of like
carbon impact
and people way overestimate how much
not using plastic straws is like
you know compared not using plastic
straws to say
like eating meat once less a week or
taking one less flight a year and it's
absurd
how much people how much weight people
put on the plastic straws thing also
this meme definitely nicely like ties
into this this the fact that
it is a relatively small number of
corporations that are responsible for a
huge
amount of environmental damage and
interestingly there was a case when i
was in south korea people were telling
me about case where
uh instead of lobbying the government to
make changes people just lobbied
corporations that the huge ones in korea
like samsung or hyundai
to actually change their procedures and
that was far more effective
so people often talk about like
individual change or governmental change
and they often miss the corporate
level which is super super important
good meme
you could say this about literally
anyone literally any any person in the
developed world
[Laughter]
this isn't climate related but i dig it
this is good this is this is the
the butterfly effect of the what is it a
butterfly flapping its wings in central
park causes a typhoon in japan or
something like that which is
which is a wonderful name for the
phenomenon because um the idea
communicates that like you know tiny
perturbations and atmospheric phenomena
cause changes
huge changes like further down the line
but also the name
was coined because um the uh
the lawrence attractor which is how we
we basically rediscovered chaos theory
the shape that it forms in
three-dimensional space it looks like a
butterfly's wings
uh because they're they're broad but
infinitesimally thin so it's actually a
very clever name and
not climate related but i'll pass we'll
let this one pass
climate say it with me everybody climate
is not
weather whether is the short term
climate is the long-term
uh americans it's not just americans
but mostly americans so it's the same
people
notice that read merchants of doubt by
nominees and eric conway
gives you an idea of why
[Laughter]
grow the lawn to provide a space for a
vulnerable bee population
i love it i i like i love like
uh sustained sustainable memes can we
make this a thing it's like wholesome
memes
we now have sustainable memes i like
that
scientific evidence of global warming
but it's cold outside
ah say it with me everybody
climate change does not mean everywhere
will always be warmer
some places will get colder climate
change just means that there is more
energy in the earth's system and that's
going to change how we redistribute
energy
across the surface of the earth that
means some areas will get hotter and on
average places will get hotter but some
places
are going to get colder not complicated
actually is it maybe it is maybe i'm
just saying that because i've studied it
for
like a decade
uh cracking open a car one with the boys
that's
so true it's it's a value system thing
isn't it like all of these people on the
left
they don't they don't give to us about
the environment they care about their
backyard nimbyism
but like the ice sheets just like a
hypothetical right
doesn't exist that makes me so sad
yes yes a thousand times this why would
consumers do this
you enabled it you 100 enabled it
consumers chose to use your product
because
you offered it at a low price because
you didn't account for negative
externalities
in like the cost benefit assessment
you did this
i've seen this one before this one is
like an altar that is the original meme
an actual comic from like a newspaper
that's actually funny
a rarity but it's so true think of a
high carbon impact as like getting your
name tattooed
on your forehead it might be useful in
the short term but oh boy you're going
to regret that in the long term
yeah think of think of all of the memes
we're going to lose because of climate
change we might gain some
but is it really worth it no would
zoomers take global warming more
seriously if it was called spicy weather
to be fair zoomers are not the problem
boomers are the problem
team trees video anyone the one where
people just comment stuff like lies
posting is not doing just just say it's
like it's the thoughts and prayers
of the environmental world nothing
means nothing rising ocean levels
threaten corgi
spiffing pruitt has entered the chat
there is actually an argument to be made
here against
using something like polar bears which
is like the frequent metaphor for global
warming
um because it's uh
well for one thing polar bears like
abstract but also it kind of trivializes
the problem a little bit it focuses down
on one small
aspect of it which is useful to help
humans comprehend it
but it does mean that you can
effectively mimify it
and it means it makes the problem seem
less
serious i like the meme though some
people have a girlfriend some people
have a boyfriend i have a
overwhelming anxiety about our climate
crisis i'm in this photo and i don't
like it
there there is like serious research
done into the mental
health impacts of people studying
climate change because
it's like going to work every day and
learning
that the world is ending it's a it
is a genuinely serious thing amongst
climate researchers i think that
you they just get numb to it i asked
actually a couple of years ago
researchers if they were optimists about
climate change and most of them still
said they were optimists
but that was the best part 10 years ago
so i'd be interested to see if that
still holds
out
[Laughter]
humans mess with climate best with
humans
how could it how dare it the climate is
like the world's most complicated
machine and
and human carbon emissions on the scale
we are currently emitting
is just throwing hammers and spanners
into the world's most complicated
machine
of course it's going to spit some cogs
at you what did you think was going to
happen
don't worry 2020 will be a great year
also
i was actually using advanced technique
there called lying
my favorite one there's no complicated
point here that's just a good meme
remember this guy this is him now
oh that does make me sad
i could make a point here about like
when we expect the arctic to be ice
sooner than you might think but that
beam actually communicates it very well
do something about this these memes are
indicating an environmental crisis we're
laughing at memes
there is a serious civilization level
threat
that we're dealing with here and of
course because it's 2021 we're making
memes about it
if the climate is changing and water
rises 10 feet people will just uh
sell their houses one small problem
this is great harry i helped out with
this video actually
of h bubble guy he asked for some advice
on certain aspects of it which is great
because i
in some way like helped make that meme a
reality and it is possibly
the best climate change related meme i
love it because it's true
ben shapiro is an example of somebody
who basically believes that
the market is going to fix everything
it's like a very neoliberal
kind of free international trade aspect
to it that the market will find a
solution
it doesn't work like that for exactly
this reason who are people
whose houses are flooded who are they
going to sell their houses to
it's a negative externality that's come
home to roost
good meme there i fixed it no more club
for warning
it might fix particular uh you know it
might actually help
like you know air quality and maybe
reduce you know some respiratory
illnesses but uh no that doesn't stop
the carbon
we are gonna have to find a use for all
these masks though i guess
what other uses do face masks have we
should reduce co2 emissions yet you
exhale co2 curious
i am very intelligent this meme every
time
every discussion change the system from
within i cannot live without emitting
co2 but i limit it as much as possible
all i'm asking is that people do exactly
the same thing it's not an excuse to be
like well we can't do it like
entirely so what's the point god i hate
that guy's smug face
i am very intelligent ask that i am very
smart
aka half of youtube comments on science
tube
and that is the last meme oh my god that
was a trip
that's the end of the memes i was sent
but i hadn't had enough
so decided to make some climate memes of
my own and you can watch that process
over on this video's page
on nebula nebula is the educational
streaming service i helped create along
with loads of other creators like legal
eagle
medlife crisis and lindsey ellis we post
our videos there earlier than on youtube
and they contain
extra content there's also nebula
exclusive content such as money by tom
scott and a cheeky video that i have
planned next month that is
definitely not safe for youtube the
crucial thing about nebula
is that it's ad free these advertising
segments that you see at the end of all
youtube videos these days is cut from
the versions on nebula
and often replaced with additional
content like in this case
instead the website runs on a
subscription model with the revenue
generated divided up between creators
based on how many people watch their
videos on the site
we've partnered up with a fantastic
documentary service curiosity stream to
offer you a deal
if you're quick and act before the 31st
of january you can get access to
curiosity stream
and nebula for less than a dollar a
month
that's over 40 off the annual price to
get access to documentaries like climate
a few degrees less
just one of dozens of documentaries on
curiosity stream about climate change
and the section of youtube you already
watch with
no adverts extra content and supporting
independent creators like me
head on over to curiositystream.com
simon clark linked in the description
to sign up and take advantage of this
great offer
less than a dollar a month and it helps
out this channel immensely
but be quick thanks to curiosity stream
for not just offering the best
documentaries on the internet
but for sponsoring this video do let me
know if you enjoyed this one
uh i really enjoyed making it and if you
felt like you maybe learned a couple of
things or just
enjoyed laughing at the memes and the
situation we're in then let me know
because i'd be very happy to do some
more videos like this one if you did
enjoy this video please do pop up a like
and let me know in the comments what you
thought if you'd like to see more
like this one and if you're new here you
can also subscribe that'd be nice here's
some examples of some more videos i've
made recently this one is a little
different so
if you if you're new here and you want
to see some more of me then there you go
there's some suggestions that just leads
me to say thank you again for watching i
hope you enjoyed and
i'll see you in the next one now lower
your carbon footprint